être ou ne pas être une femme
quelle drôle de question je suis
ingénieur en électronique dans le monde
de l'aéronautique et de la défense
alors là on comprend un peu mieux la
question quand j'ai choisi cette filière
j'ai soudain compris que j'étais en
train de devenir d'appartenir à une
espèce en voie d'apparition une espèce
rare protéger quand nous étions en
classe préparatoire nous étions cinq
filles sur 40 arrivée en école
d'ingénieur sur une promo de 110-120
nous étions 12
autant vous dire que la mixité on peut
en parler dans le métier mais bon
c'était pas spécialement gênant en soi
parce que bon quand vous avez 20 ans
c'est sympa aussi d'être pas nombreuses
et d'être chouchoutée par les copains
donc pendant les études s'étaient pas
gênant c'est quand j'ai commencé à me
rapprocher du monde de l'entreprise que
là j'ai senti quelque chose et donc dès
le premier stage je rentre dans une
grande industrie et je l'intègre à un
groupe de techniciens technicien en
automatisme je vous ai dit je suis
ingénieur en électronique est donc bon
pour ceux qui connaissent pas forcément
le le métier les techniciens
généralement sont encadrés par des
ingénieurs donc voilà généralement
l'ingénieur c'est le chef est donc
je suis dans mon groupe de techniciens
et l'un d'entre eux me dit un jour
ah bon tu veux devenir ingénieur mais
autant te dire tout de suite une femme
ne sera jamais mon chef
bon voilà ta va t'en es tu découvre la
vie bon enfin on va pas se laisser
impressionner un quoi zut donc fini mes
études avec tous mes copains et mes
copines et donc je tiens mon diplôme
chouette et je rentre dans une grande
industrie
voilà de l'aéronautique et de la défense
et je découvre encore les codes de
l'entreprise alors des codes
alors parfois un peu macho quand on voit
des groupes que de femmes on se dit
tiens mais vous parler chiffons ou alors
vous préparer les soldes les
l'entreprise est quand même bien fait
pour les hommes
quand on regarde les progressions de
carrière est ce qu on compte le nombre
de femmes qui a dans les comités de
direction
les femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
alors maintenant ça va mieux vivre la
loi copé zimmermann est alors quand aux
femmes pédégère d'entreprises du cac 40
est ce que vous savez combien il y en a
bientôt une pour l'instant autant que de
cheveux sur la tête d'un show pour vous
dire et ça ils connaissent
alors voilà les codes de l'entreprise
sont donc plutôt masculin et donc je
décide de m'adapter à ses codes de les
adopter donc j'apprends à parler foot
rugby tour de france grand prix
automobile voilà h et calais et au point
qu' il ya même des moments
un jour j'étais avec un de mes collègues
et puis plein de collègues autour
d'ailleurs et se connecte voulais
raconter une blague un peu osée et ils
étaient embêtés
il me regarde et me dit coups de tringle
on va faire comme si tu étais un mec bon
ben on va faire sa part effectivement si
finalement ce qui vous arrange tous
c'est qu'on soit quand la mecque
ça pose question mais c'est vrai que
pendant quelques temps eh ben j'ai
décidé d'adopter ses codes alors je me
suis pas déguisé quand même en vain je
tiens quand même à mon identité et tout
mais bon voilà il ya des codes il ya des
règles et si vous voulez progresser faut
quand même quelque part les adopter donc
j'ai fait ça tiraille et qui raillait
comme la plupart des femmes dans ce
métier là où on est toujours entre
est-ce que je rentre dans le moule où
mon identité à moi ma féminité qu'est-ce
que j'en fais compliqué et j'ai
progressé comme ça juste qu'à une
rencontre
on en parle beaucoup aujourd'hui qui a
été un déclic
j'étais à la veille de la préparation
enfin la veille d'une présentation face
à va quelques centaines de manager bon
alors un peu stressé et je prépare ça
avec un de mes collègues acquise yvon
écoute j'ai un problème voilà quand je
démarre ma présentation la première
minute
elle est nulle mais alors c'est une
catastrophe
j'ai mon slide
alors soit je le lis pas je dis
n'importe quoi ça aucun rapport soit je
le lis tout le monde s'endort donc voilà
la première minutes catastrophiques et
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est
catastrophique
j'ai développé un petit complexe alors
ce complexe il est venue d'une formation
que j'ai fait un jour et le coût de
cette formation qui est une formation à
la communication je sais plus très bien
elle mes collègues me dit ah meurtre en
que c'est certainement très intéressants
ce que tu dis mais alors j'ai un
problème j'ai un problème avec ta voix
alors souvenez tout à l'heure pom pom
pom pom voilà et ben moi c'est ça ta
voix elle et elle est trop haute
et donc quand tu parles j'arrive pas
être intéressé par ce que tu dis
véridique alors bon alors déjà que quand
on est une femme dans un milieu comme
celui là quand vous faites une
présentation à un public de 80 90 %
d'hommes que vous posez des questions
sur la façon dont vous vous habillez là
j'ai pas trop courtes pas trop décolleté
et cetera pas trop de maquillage bref si
en plus faut faire attention à sa voix
est là on n'y peut rien bon donc joindre
à la maison un peu choqué quand même
parce que zut quoi et j'allume la télé
et je vois claire chazal et je vous dis
ah bah ouais c'est vrai quand même les
journalistes même quand c'est des femmes
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir
voilà alors bon bain et donc depuis ce
jour là j'avais ce problème avec ma voix
et donc j'explique ça à mon collègue qui
me regardent qui diront enfin 30
est ce que tu veux leur ressembler est
ce que tu veux être comme eux bah non
non non j'ai quand même mon ego qua non
je suis comme je suis donc ne cherche
pas leur ressembler ainsi mme assume ton
identité assume sa spécificité
tu es une femme tu as une petite voix
est bas et alors si tu es là s'il pense
que tu as des choses intéressantes à
raconter ça a été une révélation
le lendemain inutile de vous dire que la
présentation s'est super bien passé que
depuis mes présentations se passe
généralement plutôt bien et que ça a
vraiment transformer ma vie et ma
carrière parce que j'étais avant en
train de rentrer dans un moule on
parlait tout à l'heure de rentrer dans
un grand c'est un peu ça et là j'étais
en train de me dire mais non je peux
être moi même et je peux m'épanouir dans
ce monde qui pourtant est très masculin
mais et alors et donc depuis mais ça je
le vois je prends du plaisir de plus en
plus à ce que je fais les différents
postes que j'ai eu depuis
finalement ce sont adaptés à mois
suivant voilà mes caractéristiques ma
personnalité etc et est donc c'est ce
que je dis aujourd'hui à un certain
nombre de femmes que je rencontre à les
jeunes filles que je rencontre aussi qui
se posent des questions sur les métiers
de l'ingénierie est ce que j'y vais ce
que j ai pas etc
mais il faut juste oser être soi même
juste se dire finalement oui voila je
suis comme je suis j'assume
j'assume ma différence j'assume ma
spécificité ma personnalité et j'avance
je trace mon chemin et je me pose pas de
question et donc ça je le dis aussi à
des jeunes que jean
contre dans le cadre d'une association
que j'adore alors c'est une association
j'espère qu'elle te rencontrera ai dit
ça s'appelle les entretiens de
l'excellence
les entretiens de l'excellence est une
association qui existe depuis dix ans et
qui s'adresse d'une part un public de
jeunes qui ont voilée entre la troisième
qui sont entre la 3e et la terminale et
qui sont dans les quartiers zone
d'éducation prioritaire
ou alors dans des zones rurales
éloignées des lieux de la formation on
va pas jusque dans le sahara mais bon à
s'éloigner voilà faut quand même se
bouger pour aller dans les hautes études
et puis on les fait rencontrer avec des
professionnels de métiers dits
d'excellence et donc au cours d'une
après midi on met face à face ces jeunes
ces professionnels au parcours
exemplaire alors on trouve des médecins
des avocats
les commissaires de police des chefs
d'entreprise des grands directeurs de
ceci de cela et et si l'objectif c'est
que au travers de ces rencontres est
depuis 10 ans il ya eu vingt mille
jeunes qui ont eu la chance de
bénéficier de ces rencontres on puisse
ouvrir ouvrir les yeux et les oreilles
donnez donnez envie donner de l'ambition
finalement cassé quelques schémas dans
lesquels ils ont pu s'enfermer dans
lesquels soit le milieu social soit la
famille soit le leur lors leur monde en
fait c'est d'enfermer est ce qu'on
essaye c'est de casser sa de leur donner
envie qu'elle a sorti de ça ils se
disent
bah oui pourquoi pas moi moi aussi j'ai
envie moi aussi je peux et moi aussi je
vais le faire et alors on s'adresse
d'une part aux enfants et on s'adresse
aussi aux parents parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte de ça aussi que justement
ce
ce blocage cette cage dont on parlait
tout à l'heure
bah des fois c'est pas le 17
des fois c'est les parents aussi et donc
on se l'expliquent aux parents ce qui
peut arriver de biens à leurs enfants ce
qu'il faut mettre en place un monde est
très pratique hein voilà moi j'habite à
tel endroit si monfils se veut aller
faire des études supérieures à bordeaux
il va falloir qu'ils se déplacent
parfois il sera une heure une heure et
demie de la maison donc il va falloir
qu'ils habitent ailleurs etc
voilà on répond à toutes ces questions
on leur donne envie et il faut vous dire
que la première fois que j'ai fait cette
rencontre je me souviens dans la salle
il y avait une jeune fille qui était de
bergerac je crois et passionné
d'aéronautique et donc nous lutte est la
première à lever la main c'est souvent
les filles d'ailleurs un qu'il avait la
main les premières et qui nous dit
j'adore l'aéronautique je suis passionné
mais est ce que vous pensez qu'une fille
peut devenir pilote votre avis qu'est ce
qu'on lui a dit on l'a encouragé
on l'a tous encouragé alors évidemment
aujourd'hui c'est dommage je ne sais pas
vous dire où elle est tout ce que
j'espère c'est que je sais qu'elle y est
allé qu'elle a essayé au moins et c'est
ça qu'on veut ce qu'on veut c'est qu'ils
essayent alors on leur donne des clés on
leur dit pas ça tombe tout cuit du ciel
il faut travailler mais si tu travailles
si tu veux tu peux
et c'est ça qu'on leur explique et donc
voilà ce sont des rencontres qui sont
absolument merveilleuse la prochaine à
bordeaux aura lieu le 19 novembre donc
j'espère que nous aurons normalement
1200 jeunes 150 intervenants avec des
profils absolument extraordinaire et des
rencontres magiques
donc je pense qu'il y aura mille deux
cents rencontres magiques ce jour là et
donc voilà tout ce que je voulais vous
dire aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
finalement c'est une histoire d'identité
c'est une histoire d'audace de volonté
d'ambition
c'est cette envie de sortie finalement
de d'un carcan de prendre ce fameux
relief dont on parle tout cet après midi
et les montagnards vous le diront le
relief
c'est difficile ça se mérite
mais quand on est arrivés en haut quel
plaisir et on a envie de recommencer
donc en fait prenons du plaisir
prenez du plaisir et que la force soit
avec vous